buongiorno a tutti insomma volevo
iniziare chiedendovi se qualcuno di voi
contunano una crafter non faceva manga
magari ok
bravi questa è la mia nonna elena è a
casa sua
ho conosciuto incontrato per la prima
volta una macchina per cucire nero ma
era una vera crafter faceva maglia
cucinava degli ottimi dolci ovviamente
cuciva è l'episodio che miri affiora
alla mente di quel tempo era erano gli
anni nei primi anni 90 avrò avuto 5 6
anni e c'era lei che cuciva questo abito
da principessa per mia cugina e io loris
baz iata volevo assolutamente imparare a
cucire però ero troppo piccola quindi
non ho potuto approfondire diciamo è una
volta che è ormai avevo l'età giusta per
imparare lei non c'era più
ori approcciato la macchina per cucire
nel 2005 quando mi sono trasferita a
milano per studiare fashion design al
politecnico
ma la vera scintilla è scoccata nel 2009
quando mi sono trasferita a vienna per
sei mesi e ho studiato all'università di
arti applicate
lì ogni studenti poteva costruirsi un
piano di studi ad hoc per il progetto
che doveva portare avanti e poteva
accedere a tutti i laboratori
dell'università metallurgia falegnameria
sartoria serigrafia qualsiasi
laboratorio aperto è quello è stato
proprio il mio primo fab lab
una volta tornata a milano ha cercato di
portare avanti questa passione di sono
entrata un po nell'ambito
dell'autoproduzione della moda etica
aperto partita iva
ho iniziato a collaborare con diversi
atelier e in particolare mi piace
raccontare della cooperativa sociale
alice che da oltre vent'anni lavora
nelle sezioni femminili delle carceri di
milano con i laboratori di sartoria
proprio con loro sono entrata e ho fatto
formazione e fuori e collaborato con la
stilista la realizzazione di alcune
collezioni
alcune hanno anche già degli interventi
diciamo un po da maker pettiniamo lì ma
nel 2014
ho iniziato la mia collaborazione presso
maker space che we make necro space di
milano mentre scrisse fab lab sono degli
spazi ma anche delle comunità sono dei
luoghi dove le macchine a controllo
numerico come laser carta stampanti 3d
entrano contatto con la creatività delle
persone sono infatti le persone
il cuore di questi spazi loro portare
dei saperi e le conoscenze condividerle
o il carburante un carburante che
permette la produzione di progetti
veramente particolari
la vera rivoluzione dei maker è stata
quella di rendere le tecnologie
democratiche diciamo che con
l'inserimento
con lo sviluppo e rilascio soprattutto
di progetti open source è stata
possibile la digital fabrication con
digital fabrication intendiamo il fatto
di avere delle tecnologie che vengono
utilizzate dalle persone ma non in
maniera singolo quindi non con il vero
acquisto di una stampante 3d ma
utilizzate dalla comunità e nella
comunità c'è un continuo scambio di
saperi e di conoscenze quindi la
macchina non si ferma solo a fare il suo
dovere ma può creare nuove macchine come
in questo caso questo è un progetto di
barbarie mar
è una macchina da maglieria circolare
completamente autoprodotto e realizzata
dalla comunità dei lakers face con
stampanti 3d macchine taglio laser e
arduino dalla digital fabrication anti
cheat al fashion il passo veramente
breve con claudia scarpa
abbiamo realizzato una delle prime
ricerche in ambito tessile sviluppate
proprio all'interno di un maker space e
abbiamo cercato di dare un senso è la
cosa che ci sembrava più interessante da
fare era creare un modulo formativo
quindi rendere o per il metodo che
abbiamo scoperto e condividerlo con gli
altri
il modulo formativo di digital fashion
prevede un approccio non accademico
questo cosa significa che nel momento in
cui noi andiamo a insegnare software non
c'è un mero apprendimento frontale ma
tutti sono invitati a collaborare tra di
loro mentre imparano utilizzare questi
software sono poi ci arriveremo in pieno
stile peer education quindi educazione
tra pari larkin by doing è un'altra
tecnica
e noi recuperiamo dal mondo maker
definiamo che significa imparare facendo
gli studenti una volta ha preso le
tecnologie vengono messe la prova e
iniziano a scoprire facendo quindi
realizzando dei primi prototipi il
funzionamento dei macchinari se i
materiali rispondono bene
insomma imparare facendo significa anche
fare degli errori
quindi ci poniamo sull'apprendimento
tramite l'errore l'errore non è un male
ma è un momento di crescita un momento
di crescita per poter migliorare il
proprio progetto e quindi raccontarlo a
termine capire se quello che stiamo
facendo e porterà effettivamente al
quello che speravamo
insomma al prodotto finale
il software home perché utilizziamo sono
due e sono in skype inkscape è un
software per il disegno vettoriale
ottimo con dei plugin veramente speciali
per la laser cut a una comunità molto
sviluppata ne abbiamo sentito parlare
prima quindi le comunità sono
fondamentali per questi software per che
ne permettono un miglioramento continuo
è un inserimento di nuovi plugin e
valentina project
valentina è il primo caso open source
per il disegno della carta modelli di
moda si si disegna in maniera
parametrica quindi utilizzando delle
formule matematiche e ge la cosa molto
importante che gira su moltissimi
sistemi operativi
ecco una cosa importante da dire in
merito valentina e che c'ha anche
quest'anno comunità molto forte quindi
quando noi lo raccontiamo all
ai nostri studenti diciamo sempre che
devono iniziare a collaborare con la
community collaborare con la community
significa innanzitutto testare software
e capire se ci sono dei bachi e in tal
caso comunicarli ai programmatori o
comunque alla comunità in generale anche
agli altri users significa anche
tradurlo in varie lingue
loro sanno attraverso una piattaforma
online significa anche creare dei
tutorial in modo tale che altri users
siano in grado di imparare a utilizzarlo
la cosa importante è che valentina non è
orientata all'utente finale ma orientata
la community
quindi non sarà un software adatto a
un'impresa ma sicuramente adatto a
diverse professioni
facendo un passo indietro noi abbiamo
presentato digital division nel 2015
alla rom maker faire ed è stato
annoverato 310 migliori progetti da
start up italia e da lì abbiamo iniziato
a fare i nostri esperimenti abbiamo
iniziato come un modulo formativo base
di 10 ore dove gli studenti iniziano a
lavorare con skype ea elaborare i propri
prototipi con la laser
la cosa interessante in questo amico
appunto e che in così poche ore le
studentesse che arrivano da diversi
ambiti diciamo riescono a realizzare un
capo che poi portano a casa e possono
indossare o finte realizzare con le
diverse appunto tecnologie che noi
abbiamo il meter space abbiamo
sviluppato poi un altro modulo formativo
informativo pro che dura molto di più
infatti 90
permette di approfondire l'utilizzo dei
due software inscape e valentina in
parallelo nella realizzazione dei
modelli e e prevede uno sviluppo un po
differente perché il numero di persone
che vi partecipano e maggiore quindi è
possibile lavorare su lippi ma prima di
questo facciamo una piccola sessione di
design thinking per arrivare a una
divisione in gruppi proprio e ogni
gruppo lavora su un concept ib verso
lavorare sui concept è molto importante
perché permette poi ogni singolo gruppo
di fare una ricerca di mercato capire
quali sono i modelli migliori per
portare avanti appunto il progetto e
quindi la cosa molto importante anche
che lavorando in gruppo avviene uno
scambio di conoscenze tra le diverse
persone che partecipano al corso questi
sono alcuni esempi dei capi realizzati
dalle ragazze del corso
abbiamo dei modelli semplici con
ovviamente delle elaborazioni grafiche
abbiamo avuto un gruppo che ha veramente
sviluppato tantissimo la parte sui
software inventandosi una serie di capi
sulla lavorazione 3d quindi passando dal
kirigami a una chiocciola creata con per
paura quindi la cosa veramente
interessante che ogni gruppo ha avuto
ha avuto un proprio focus ha potuto
sviluppare diverse tematiche anche in
base alle precedenti alle loro
precedenti informazioni comunque
professioni laurent ho lavorato su degli
abiti che non prevedevano le cuciture ad
esempio quindi con incastro i fori un
lavoro con delle corde e loro hanno
lavorato su ii verdi di maglia quindi
forare il tessuto diversi tipi di
tessuto per ricreare delle delle
immagini di questo tipo quindi ricreare
il mondo della maglia una cosa che
volevo dire rispetto a questi moduli e
che chiunque può imparare a creare dei
capi d'abbigliamento di questo tipo non
solamente stilisti e fashion designer
infatti la vera forza di questo modulo e
che avevamo all'interno delle dei
professionisti che proveniamo dei più
diversi mondi dal dell'ingegneria edile
all l'esperto di marketing dal c'è stata
veramente uno scambio di conoscenze e
tutti hanno imparato veramente
utilizzare questi software nonostante la
diversità dei campi da cui arrivavano si
sono uniti in gruppo e sono riusciti a
creare un sistema di propri soldi di
realizzare dei capi che altrimenti da
singoli non non avrebbero potuto fare
però è che spesso non lavoriamo
solamente sui tessili sui tessuti
abbiamo un'altra ricerca una ricerca si
chiama digitalmente e una delle uniche
ricerche in ambito maglieria digitale
dei fab lab italiani
stata portata da noi la claudia scarpa è
sviluppata con la forza della comunità
di cittadini e sia un modulo formativo
che una ricerca per l'appunto claudio
scarpa si forma alla scuola di
famosissimo educatore e progettisti
minimalista italiano che ronzoni e una
grafica e la cosa interessante è che ha
portato la sua ricerca di dimensionale
all'interno del mondo della maglieria e
del meeting in generale ma la cosa
veramente interessante e la
collaborazione che ha avuto con un
programmatore e di un esperto di
elettronica all'interno del maker space
assieme a loro sono riusciti a fare la
king di una macchina da maglieria
elettronica
questo ha permesso a claudia di poter
realizzare dei capi dal di modelli
aperti quindi lei poteva realizzare dei
disegni totalmente nuovi non so se avete
presente le le vecchie macchine da
maglieria erogano dei pattern veramente
tristi un po anni 80 invece grazie a
questo ci pitino questo può in realtà è
una scelta si chiama aiab o liars
beautiful
ed è appunto un componente sviluppato
per i programmatori tedeschi che
applicato a una meno 1 permette tramite
un software python di
a claudia di realizzare dei pattern
tramite chimp che è un software per
l'editing fotografico dove il pixel e un
punto magno sostanzialmente è appunto
realizzarli con una macchina da
maglieria
beh questo risultato la cosa veramente
interessante secondo me e che grazie
alla king di questa macchina è stato
possibile a claudia realizzare una serie
di zaini questi che sono veramente un
prodotto fatto e finito non è più un
prototipo quindi non si parla più di
prototipi a si parla di prodotto fatto e
finito con una tecnologia open source
ok cosa ci aspettiamo dal futuro beh
sicuramente entrambe le strade sono solo
all'inizio di un percorso che noi
vogliamo portare avanti l'idea è quella
di continuare ad alimentare una comunità
una community sia offline
quindi per il co design per le pratiche
di condivisione delle pratiche proprio
che online
quindi per le pratiche di share e
condividere
attraverso internet i progetti che
vengono realizzati sia all'interno dei
nostri corsi che semplicemente con il
metodo che noi insegniamo o comunque che
proponiamo la cosa veramente
interessante oltre appunto alla
condivisione l'idea di avere una
community e così via e che il fatto di
portare la tecnologia e nell'ambito
della moda permette anche alle donne di
avvicinarsi alle tecnologie spesso per
un motivo o per un altro le donne
rimangono un attimo al di fuori di tutti
questi diciamo ambiti tecnologici
magari sono più vicini ad altre realtà è
invece digital fashion ancora la voglia
di riavvicinarle al alle tecnologie ma
non solamente per la moda questa è una
porta d'ingresso diciamo per poter
ridare la la grinta a chi l'ha persa
magari di ricominciare con un lavoro
insomma ho perso però adesso viene la
parte divertente
la cosa bella del di una comunità è che
un po come una famiglia
la famiglia vive di rapporti crisi di di
valore e questo valore viene dato dalla
fiducia la mia comunità è quella di
maker e i valori che noi abbiamo solo
quelli della condivisione dello scambio
di saperi questo scambio di saperi è un
po diciamo quello che colma il gradino
il gap che c'è stato tra la mia
generazione e ad esempio quella di mia
nonna
quindi tutto quello che la tv
l'artigianato al saper fare è andato
perso per un mancato collegamento tra
generazioni viene colmato dai maker
diciamo che la cosa più interessante
sicuramente è che quello che il maker
hanno creato attraverso la comunità le
community gli spazi non è solamente un
mero fare ma è un momento di
condivisione che non finisce lì ma va
oltre
quindi apre la strada a nuovi metodi e
pratiche di lavoro